most of the skulls and bones found in
this Museum in the Savo National Park
were collected nearly six decades ago
that's when a drought killed thousands
of elephants
scientists informally call the museum
the elephant graveyard
Frederick Lala has been collecting such
remains for years for research he says
elephants and other herbivores are again
finding it increasingly difficult to get
food and water
the government says more than 200
elephants and other games have died this
year we understand that land is
shrinking some of the dispersal areas
that elephants used to go to during the
dry seasons or during the droughts most
of them are now being occupied by people
the rainy season usually starts in Kenya
around this time and although some areas
are receiving rainfall and zavo and
others it's been sporadic
you don't have to go very far to find
carcasses in this park most of the
animals that have died are grazes and
browsers uh Park officials that we've
spoken to say that they are trying to do
the best they can they say this is a
devastating season
large animals are walking farther in
such a water and forage their space is
shrinking as human populations are
growing the situation has not been very
good because we've even seen most of our
Rivers drying up aggressively we've seen
a lot of most of our areas remaining
bare land and that is a serious effect
because now there's very limited forage
for both wildlife and even a livestock
those working in the park say this
season to the worst drought they've seen
in recent years but the fact they're
happening more frequently is worrying
getting water into some of the vast
areas of the park has been an issue
issues of
the erectiveness of the rainfall we have
water pumps within the park but most of
them are not able to sustain Wildlife
over a longer period of time
and there's also an issue of siltation
of some of the rivers
Rangers are tasked with collecting
carcasses particularly those of
elephants they remove the tasks to
prevent poachers taking them but they
say poaching is less of a threat to the
animals than climate change Catherine
soy at the Savo National Park